الثوره الكبيره التي نراها ونعيشها في
عالمنا اليوم مع الذكاء الاصطناعي بدات
تتكشف مساوئها وبدات تظهر مخاطرها الامثله
اصبحت كثيره من عمليات الاحتيال عبر
الهاتف الى صور مفبركه واليوم هناك مستوى
جديد
مخيفردستيفانو الام المذهوله تخبر كيف
استخدم مجموعه من المجرمين الذكاء
الاصطناعي الاستنساخ صوت ابنتها
قدرها مليون دولار كجزء من مخطط صوتي جديد
مرعب
وجدت على الهاتف ولم اشك ابدا في انها
كانت هي هذا هو الجزء الفظيع الذي اوصلني
حقا الى الانهيار وعندما حاولت الاتصال
بهاتفها اجابته على الرغم من انها كانت في
صف التزلج في ولايه اخرى ليتضح بانها ليست
مخطوفه
تاتي هذه القنبله وسط زياده في مخططات
انتحال هويه المتصل او حتى في الاعمال
المزوره كصوره البابا فرنسيس بابا روما
هنا الذي يظهر كا ايقونه الموضه لهذا
الموسم وقد يذهب الامر الى مستوى خطيرا
كهذه الحاله التي تم تسجيلها في بلجيكا
عندما اقدم رجل على الانتحار بعدما تحدث
الى شيء روبوت الدردشه في تطبيق الذكاء
الاصطناعي
لا نريد ايضا ان تقوم برامج الدردشه
الاليه بالترويج لعادات الاكل غير الصحيه
او للتشيع على اساءه استخدام العقاقير
وبعد الكثير من الحوادث تم تعديل هذه
البرامج من قبل الشركات التي تنتج هذه
التطبيقات ولذا اعتقد ان هناك متسعا
لمطوري هذه الانظمه لانشاء حواجز الحمايه
التي نرغب في رؤيتها
عندما جربنا التطبيق الذي يعمل على نموذج
لغه ذكاء اصطناعي مفصل لم يشجع على
الانتحار ما يعني ان القائمين على التطبيق
عدلوا بالمحتوى بعد الحادثه في بلجيكا
الجدل داير الان على اعلى المستويات في
الولايات المتحده حول مخاطر الذكاء
الاصطناعي الاداره الامريكيه القرب
المسؤوليه على عاتقي شركات التكنولوجيا
وكبار رواد هذا القطاع منقسمون بين مؤيدا
للذكاء ومعارض له كونه خطرا على البشريه
سليمان العربيه واشنطن لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات